hey what's going on is bill burns it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday November 5th 2018 what's going on
how are you
oh that's phenomenal isn't that
wonderful
hey everybody I don't know if you've
heard I don't know if you've been on a
TV or near a TV I don't know if you
stream your thoughts at this point
through some sort of algorithm on a
world wide network I don't know if
you've heard this is for Americans only
by the way people from the United States
of America everybody else you know if
you're in Australia just go stick a beat
on something and [ __ ] eat it during
this time all right because this has
nothing to do with you and that giant
[ __ ] can of what Foster's larger
whatever the [ __ ] it is that any you
[ __ ] drink down there that's why you
stick it in a little [ __ ] powder keg
like you're just trying to get rid of it
sent it on our way right that beard
that's the bush light of Australia
anyways I've never had one I just judge
it by the size of the can I'm like it's
that [ __ ] good why you giving it away
by the bucketful anyways for the people
that this podcast truly represents and
that would be the greatest people on
this planet the people of the United
States of America particularly the white
people I'm [ __ ] with you going on
Trump on here sorry I'm reading a trump
speech it's a first draft of a Trump
speech evidently tomorrow I mean I
didn't know this I don't know if you
aware this but I was not aware that
tomorrow is evidently a very important
day in politics quite possibly the most
important political day in history and
you know something I had no idea but
thank God all of these celebrities have
taken time out of their day
to let me know how important it is you
know what I mean
just when you think a celebrity cannot
give more of themselves on screen after
they've been driven over in a golf cart
and add their [ __ ] here poofed by
some [ __ ] poor bastard in a trailer
right wolf - poof whatever the [ __ ] it
is thank God you know something and I've
been so inspired by all of these
celebrities letting me know what is
going on in my country you know what I
mean why would I listen to to two people
who I don't know are in that business
for a living why would I listen to them
when I can listen to somebody who's on a
sitcom and you know what I've been so
inspired I actually think that I'm gonna
uh I'm gonna you oh look who's calling
in here a little face time here my kid
oh hey buddy
hi hi Haney I'm doing the podcast on
lily recording right now you guys are on
the podcast hi sweetheart
hey do you know tomorrow is a very
important election day I had no idea
and then somebody the third lead in an
x-man movie let me know that I need to
get out there and vote yeah I don't know
why they're doing that I have a bad
feeling that it's gonna drive it the
other way I was just in it I was just in
a car service coming over from the
airport and the guy goes I'm voting
Allred tomorrow already all right I
gotta get back to the podcast I'll see
you guys later
bye buddy bye sweetheart
all right I'll see it a minute yeah
anyway so what I think I'm gonna do I am
going to loan my podcast celebrity to
try and aspire some of you to get out
there tomorrow
get out there and vote and when I say
vote I don't mean go out and decide who
you think is the right candidate I want
you to go out there and vote who for who
I want you to vote for okay
I'm loaning my podcast celebrity and I
feel like more so than that I'm actually
gonna be honest with you as a person in
your public ears rather than just being
like trying to be like none you know
committal here and just say get out
there and vote I want you to vote who I
want you to vote for okay I don't know
who to vote for
maybe maybe somebody that hosts a game
show could tell me I watched CNN Fox
News all the time i'm informed i read
the sunday New York Times shut up Jesus
do these [ __ ] people understand that
there's there's engineers and doctors
you know too stupid to name another
smart job veterinarian the guy who knows
how to hook up your [ __ ] cable I mean
these are smart people they know it's an
important [ __ ] election they know who
they're voting for all right I got a bad
feeling that they're gonna get this
wrong the same way they got the election
wrong you know I actually think that if
celebrities wanted this blue wave they
should shut up
because do you know people who are on
the red side are also watching this [ __ ]
it's like you're broadcasting to the
Japanese during World War two when
you're going to attack why would you do
that you got to get on your own
frequency right Oh
who should I vote for maybe too near
could tell me hey I like that guy's
movies maybe I like his political
choices you member back in the day when
you just you know you didn't bring up
politics and you didn't bring up
religion and you sat there and you ate
your [ __ ] cheese sandwich you know
and you just said that was it
every [ __ ] you know you got to get
out there and vote and by vote I mean
vote who I'm gonna vote for oh my god
what is wrong with this country how come
everybody doesn't see it the way I see
it anyways
having said that I usually vote but I'm
gonna be here in New York and I didn't
file for the absentee thing you know so
whoever's not liking this should be
happy that I just cancelled out my vote
you know and one of the most important
elections of all time and you know why
it's important because the same five
corporations that have the money on all
the horses in the race this time decided
to just put it on one side of the ball
evidently so we will move towards a more
prosperous future for the middle class
because someone's finally gonna regulate
the bank's again is that what we're
voting for I don't know I have no idea
hey you know what I'm gonna loan I'm
gonna loan my podcast celebrity right
now and I'm going to solve the problems
of the Middle East right now the first
thing I would do I would go over there I
would tell everybody to grow up okay as
far as I can tell you all worship the
same thing no this is what I would do I
would I would I would break up with Iraq
that's the first thing I would do I
would just sit down and just say listen
I rec I'm not happy this isn't working
out
I know I know I came in like gangbusters
I moved in within a week with this just
whole relationship just moved way too
quickly
all right and I just you know it's not
that I I love you but I don't love you
in a way that makes me want to stay and
I would just get the [ __ ] out you can
keep the Starbucks and all these [ __ ]
things right all right switch over to
solar power I would do all of this on
the same day by the way in my world you
can actually do this switch over to sell
the power take that lunatic over a Tesla
you know the he looks like the guy in in
McShane if he had a nervous breakdown or
so I don't know what the [ __ ] that
[ __ ] guy right I was just all
electric all the [ __ ] time right I'd
have a big campaign when I bring back
the electric slide and everybody [ __ ]
enough mouth breathers would do it and
they would get behind it and then we're
not no more money to the Middle East all
right for oil then they'd all go
bankrupt in a second we leave they go
back to kicking the [ __ ] out of each
other you know what I mean the same way
when Russia left Eastern Europe
everybody was happy for about three days
then they all started killing each other
again they were like oh yeah where were
we
that's right God said we're better right
they just went break back to that [ __ ]
see you leave yeah you got all the
[ __ ] solar power and all that [ __ ]
[ __ ] going on I don't know if you notice
about the Middle East Middle East always
reminded me of there was used to be this
store in the south shore Plaza that I
used to go to before they did the
remodel you know when it was all brown
and 70s looking I swear to God I think
the floor was made out of vinyl there's
some sort of rubber anyways they used to
have these little kiosks in the middle
of all these big stores almost like like
little moons to these giant [ __ ]
planets of stores and one of them was
called wicks and sticks
and all they sold was candles and even
as a little kid I was like how would
they stay and open like that's all they
sell you know if people ever stopped
[ __ ] or doing voodoo like these
people are gonna be in trouble so I look
at like the Middle East like they're
like a giant Wixon sticks like where
wicks and sticks just just sold candles
they're just selling oil that's their
main thing if you stop buying their oil
they don't have any money they don't
have any money they can't finance a
[ __ ] military right I mean while they
can't have endangered species as pets so
that's a twofer right there they slowly
go out of [ __ ] business we're over
here with their [ __ ] uh I don't know
[ __ ] electric cars and [ __ ] not
saying it's cleaner for the environment
but it gets you out of that [ __ ] if
elected tomorrow ladies and gentlemen I
will I will present a three-day plan to
get us out of the Middle East and off of
oil that would be implemented
immediately despite the crushing effects
on the economy I'm sorry I'm just I've
just I don't need somebody who is in
[ __ ] third Rock from the Sun you know
talking about this but you know at the
end of the day I am NOT voting I would
have voted but I'm just on the road so
what am I supposed to do well bill you
could apply for an absentee ballot well
I would but the people that I vote for
never win cuz they ain't the Democrat
state Republican Party
I vote for those lunatics those people
that elect I don't know man if we voted
for this guy and he got in I don't know
either things would get better or
everything would be on fire like those
are the people that I vote for so maybe
I shouldn't vote maybe I'm one of those
people
we'll be right back with podcast
celebrities who don't vote as a podcast
celebrity I just like saying that that
makes me feel important speaking of
important I have a couple of important
announcements to make I'm gonna be at
Madison Square Garden on Wednesday the
day after the election I think I'm still
gonna be like telling people what they
should vote for that's how full of
myself I am the day after the election
you know what you should have done
you know like somebody calls up a sports
show the day after their team [ __ ]
loses all right
important announcement my patreon page
wwp Tree on comm slash borrow five bucks
a month every month you get two episodes
of uninformed with me and old Joey roses
I got a see live from the live Monday
morning podcasts that I filmed I didn't
for any live studio on it but in Phoenix
you can download that from the patreon
app to stream that and new uninformed
episodes or download directly to your
phone I have behind the scenes the forum
behind the scenes a backstage I should
say and I have some helicopter video and
I'm just going to keep adding to that
every month it's at WWF Adrian calm / /
that's it what else do I have I think
that was it
other than that I went up and I visited
my family back east and I went to the
Patriots Green Bay Packers game
obviously was very excited with the
outcome of that game
I was nervous because Aaron Rodgers is
such a [ __ ] beast and yeah I was
nervous about our defense against him
and you know played a little bend don't
break in the red zone he kind of had all
day to pass for most of the game but
when it counted we got in his [ __ ]
grill and made it happen
and I had great seats
you know after telling Jimmy Kimmel that
I said up up top with the [ __ ] real
people I actually got into one of those
boxes snow sitting right in the front
[ __ ] row they had the window open and
[ __ ] it was great so I was like cold but
then when I walked into the back near
the food I was all warm like those in
somebody's living room I got treated
like an absolute king so I want to thank
the Patriots when we got the whole trip
I got to see the the trophies I got to
talk to Andre
Tippett I mean it was it was it was
incredible it's [ __ ] incredible and
then I watched arguably two of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time I mean
one of them is the greatest quarterback
of all time and then the other one I
don't know you know what are we gonna
put him he's only halfway done you know
he's just [ __ ] kicking the [ __ ] out
of everybody he's on track right he's on
track to be what top five ever he's got
to be you know I bet if he what if he
wasn't doing what he was doing in Green
Bay you know if he was doing it in a
different city like New York he probably
already be there you gotta work twice as
hard twice as hard to Green Bay I feel
like I can you imagine me in the
greatest quarterback of all time and
you're in Buffalo New York Green Bay
Wisconsin like how long would it take
people to notice we're taking collars no
it was an amazing game and except that's
maybe the third time I've seen Aaron
Rodgers play live he just always leaves
one of those guys where he starts to run
and then he can throw the [ __ ] ball
you think all right he's gonna run for
like eight yeah he just got 30 yards
like how good he is at that is it's it's
like drives you up the [ __ ] wall when
you're watching your team because you're
like tackling okay they got him go he
slipped away now that tackle before he
gets a first down [ __ ] throws it down
the goddamn field how many people like
bitching at some of our quarterbacks
it's like dude that ain't them they've
been running around back there for like
six seconds like something should have
happened by now they shouldn't still
have to be covering a receiver
but anyways I kind of called it before
the game I kind of feeling Josh Gordon
was gonna have a breakout game which I
feel like he did I couldn't tell I
wasn't watching any sort of broadcast
let's say he jammed his fingers or
something on two plays in a row he was
looking at his hands I hope he's alright
and then that Patterson dude just took
over before the half just unstoppable
just handing the ball off to him
this hybrid running back wide receiver I
mean how perfect is that for Bella
checks offense so here we go with six
and two but [ __ ] Kansas City won
again so there what there's seven and
one I don't [ __ ] know I got a kid now
I have no idea so as of right now we
would play Kansas City at home provided
we got to the AFC championship game and
I tell you that would be that'd be a
tall order trying to beat those guys two
times in one year once again people
freaking out about my homes they threw a
ball like 90 yards all you mean like dub
Williams did 30 years ago
sorry I've never seen anything like this
alright LSU vs. Alabama oh Jesus
oh that one hurt oh did that one hurt I
was like Alabama hasn't [ __ ] played
anybody let's look at that [ __ ]
schedule right because this is what I
was doing I was like you know something
even though our [ __ ] best defensive
player is gonna be on the bench for the
first [ __ ] half I feel like we're
gonna hang with them then the other kid
comes in maybe he can you know
tip the scale and LSU's favor that did
not happen
can I spell Alabama Alabama football
schedule 2018 let's listen to these
powerhouses that Alabama has played
Mississippi State that's not bad
Auburn oh this is what they have left
I'm sorry sorry hang on a sec hang on a
second
Auburn they play Auburn every day of
every [ __ ] Thanksgiving bill alright
they played Louisville
151 214 then they played Mississippi
then they played Louisiana Lafayette
then they played Missouri or whatever I
think I'm [ __ ] up these none of these
teams are ranked they played Arkansas
State they played Texas A&M not
Alabama's fault that Texas A&M is not
good right now
then they played Arkansas not their
fault they played Tennessee they played
Missouri this is LSU is the first [ __ ]
ranked team they played all year so I'm
thinking like well they've finally
[ __ ] playin somebody let's see what
happens and they went in there and they
just [ __ ] kicked him right in the dick
I mean it just offense couldn't do [ __ ]
the defense just dominated him it's it's
like they just stuck a rag in their
mouth and [ __ ] wrap some duct tape
right around him no it was it and just
repeatedly kicked him in the nuts slowly
for four straight quarters twenty-nine
to nothing so almost a lebanner haters
out there you know
yeah they don't play [ __ ] but it's not
their fault it's not their fault that
everybody kind of sucks that they're
playing but then when they do play a
number three team they [ __ ] destroyed
them
so they got Mississippi State and then
the biggest challenge of the year they
play Citadel and then they got uh Auburn
and then for some reason there's a game
on the first of December I would have
thought that that was their last one
they're playin Georgia so they got some
teams coming up not really but let's
just say they'll be nice and rested for
when they play for yet another
championship but you know something as
much as people [ __ ] about that you know
they're easy scheduled then they get
into the championship game and more
times than not they win you know as
opposed to Ohio State I remember a few
years ago they [ __ ] they Penn State
beat them straight up and then also won
the Big Ten championships and for some
reason Penn State
didn't get in but Ohio State did and
then Iowa State went down there I got
their [ __ ] shorts yanked down I'm in
way over my head right now I don't even
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about but
I can just tell you as a podcast
celebrity your vote on who should be who
should make the NCAA college football
playoff is extremely important it's
extremely important that this Saturday
coming up is one of the most important
Saturdays in college football history
and who would know better than a
celebrity podcaster all that sounds
better doesn't it
I'm gonna have to put that on my [ __ ]
I guess concern put that on my Wikipedia
page comedian actor celebrity podcaster
[Music]
please don't put that on there I've
already said to do it so now it's too
tough now it's done anyways so I'm
hanging here in New York I'm gonna do my
little tune-up show tonight bounce
around some clubs here in New York
looking forward to that and then I got
my big shoe on on Wednesday so I'm just
sitting here and then I got I got three
shows in Chicago at the Chicago Theatre
on Thursday Friday and Saturday and then
all freckles is [ __ ] done for the year
I've done for the year
so I mean not I may get some local shows
that I'm doing but and I will not be
doing [ __ ] again until I go out to
Eastern Europe which I already made fun
of on this podcast when are we
announcing those dates I don't know I
think I just pictured the hedge I just
picked the headshot they were going to
use or something to that nature so any
day now and oh you know what [ __ ] this
I'm just gonna tell you this I want to
tell you the [ __ ] cities I'm gonna be
in but I'm not going to tell you the
dates all I'm gonna do is tell you that
it [ __ ] it it starts
on what is it January 2nd alright here
we go let's see if I could find it here
oh-ho-ho Billy when a you're going to
[ __ ] Eastern Europe well where the
[ __ ] are they well that's not it oh why
is it [ __ ] [ __ ] what why
aren't you showing me what the [ __ ] I
want all right you know what I'm just
gonna put in Eastern Europe how about
just Europe Eastern Europe okay all
right
all right I'm just gonna I'm gonna be in
Prague Vienna Berlin Warsaw Latvia you
know whether it is Lithuania Estonia
Bulgaria Cologne Munich often Baca
Germany Budapest Hungary I might have
read those kind of backwards that's
gonna be from January 3rd until Sunday
January 13th ten days and I'm bringing
Paul virzi with me and he's gonna go
over there with his [ __ ] blue Yankee
hat and his [ __ ] joy dude
Eastern Europe Jordan sixes over over we
I'm actually it came in town early
because we had a surprise birthday party
for Paul and when I tell you like you
know when you go to those things and
like the persons kind of figured it out
and then they try to act like the
surprise and you know that they're not
like virzi legit had no [ __ ] clue he
was coming down the stairs and I could
tell the way he was talking it was at
this restaurant the way he was talking
to this guy I was like oh my god this
guy has like no clue and then I was I
got like nervous for a second like is he
gonna have like a [ __ ] heart attack
what if he just breaks down and starts
crying you know just gets really [ __ ]
awkward I got I got like really I don't
like doing that too
you know what I mean you know let him
know what's going on he just came
walking around the corner we all just go
surprised and he did like a [ __ ]
double take put his hand up to his face
and then just walked out of the room for
a second but it was funny everybody
laughed and then he came back and oh my
god we had a great time I was like this
whiskey tasting thing it was just
amazing
it was [ __ ] amazing this guy was
given us all this whole [ __ ] history
lesson on whiskey to a bunch of
comedians so it's like we're in class
with the subject we always wanted to
take but at the end of the day we're all
class clowns everybody's trying to outdo
each other and this guy Ethan who did
the tour just handled it like a champ
you know we gave him [ __ ] a little bit
he gave a [ __ ] back it was it was just
such a [ __ ] great time then he had
somebody that can roll in cigars it was
really uh it was amazing and then I went
up to the Patriots game yeah you know
this this is what it's like people to be
a celebrity pot RMI stuff at that joke
alright anyways so I'm back here in New
York and I was watching today on ESPN
they said the Lakers hit a new low in
the LeBron era it's like the heat just
[ __ ] started it seems like a month
into it Magic Johnson said that on a
two-year plant the first year's gonna be
rough and then they're gonna clear all
this cap space and they're gonna buy a
bunch of people and make a run at
[ __ ] gold estate I mean you think the
guy said that he said that's what I'm
gonna do I don't understand why ESPN is
trying to make me act like this is like
this big failure and Luke Walton needs
to be fired
they said it's a two-year plan were
barely [ __ ] 19 two months into this
Jesus Christ he [ __ ] ESPN I swear to
god they're worse than CNN and Fox so I
don't watch any of those channels I just
said tell me who won the game getting me
all [ __ ] anxious we had a meeting
with Luke Walton
they said it wasn't you know it didn't
concern his job but could it bend his
kidneys sorry
anyways I actually been going to the gym
out here in New York and uh you know I
had a little bit of set a little bit of
a setback with my shoulder and now I'm
back the person I was working with was
telling me what I could do like a
hundred twenty pounds like ten times on
the lat pulldown with the weight that
I'm at I could attempt to do a pull-up
my shoulder would be but you know one
two three which means I would just do
one and you know I took a few days off I
tried to come back where I left off I
was up to 110 pounds and I felt a little
tweak
I [ __ ] stopped immediately shut the
whole thing down ice my shoulder and I
was fine but I had to go back down to
about 75 pounds just these [ __ ]
rotator cuffs they're such they're so
delicate you know to me it's like you
know and like a out like someone who's
just a needy self-centered [ __ ] like
their group of friends it's just like a
I don't know what their deal is they're
like it's like this entourage of people
like that's kind of like what a rotator
cuff is like that person you know if
your shoulder muscles were a bunch of
different people bill what are you
talking about I don't know I'm just
trying to kill [ __ ] time let me read
some advertising here how about that huh
did I did I copy and paste the
advertising I don't think I did I don't
think I did here we go my age is
probably gonna give me [ __ ] for reading
those [ __ ] names of those cities I
mean what am I supposed to do up and
I've been pre hyping it for a while by
the way that my Eastern European tour is
going to be one of the most important
stand-up tours in the history of Eastern
European stand-up tours by bald
redheaded males who grew up in
Massachusetts south of Boston all right
oh my bookie everybody a sure watch for
footballs foam when would you like to
have a little bit of [ __ ] action
order
but it's more entertaining when you have
some action on the games guys you've
heard me talk about this for weeks and
some of you are still on the sideline
like a bunch of Mary's whether you're an
expert or a rookie you should be betting
my bookie that my bookie if you're the
kind of guy that likes to bet a little
and win a lot like playing the numbers
on roulette you can create a big parlay
pick three teams to win and if you hit
all three you could turn a hundred
dollars into six hundred bucks I never
do the parlay that's like [ __ ] doing
a murder with somebody else you know
somebody's gonna rat somebody up you
know what I mean I do individual bets
anyways there's just so much to bet on
playoff baseball basketball hockey
primetime fights and more also make sure
to follow bet at Ellis are at bet my
bookie on Twitter or Instagram they
personally respond to every mention in
DM not to mention they've given away
nearly ten thousand dollars in free
money to their fellow to their followers
this football season you'll be the first
to know as soon as the odds and put on
props are posted log on to my bookie
right now don't miss out on your last
opportunity to collect the industry's
biggest bonus use promo code Burr and
you'll get your first deposit matched
100% that's promo code burb you are are
you play you when you get paid well you
lose you pay and maybe your girlfriend
breaks up with you just giving you all
the possibilities here Jesus Christ I
don't read Allah's [ __ ] frame bridge if
you've been listening to this show
you've heard me talk about frame bridge
the most important framed bridges
tomorrow on Tuesday they make it super
easy and affordable to frame your
favorite things from art I just
immediately pictured so many framing
their dick for some reason from art
prints and posters to the travel photos
sitting on your phone here's how it
worked just go to frame bridge comm and
upload your photo or they'll send you
packaging to safely mail in your mailing
your physical pieces
and we're back to Dick's again preview
your item online in any frame style
choose your favorite or get free
recommendations from their talented
designers the expert team at frame
bridge will custom frame your item and
deliver your finished piece directly to
your door ready to hang instead of the
hundreds you pay at a framing store
their prices started just thirty nine
dollars and all the shipping is free
plus my listeners will get 15% off their
first order at frame bridge comm when
they use my code bur get started today
frame your photo or send the perfect
gift for weddings birthdays and special
events go to frame bridge calm and use
promo code burro you'll save an
additional 15% off your first order just
go to frame bridge calm promo code / hey
frame bridge calm promo code burn
alright there's three left let's take a
break here shall we from reading my
[ __ ] eyes hurt let me see
feminists cheerleaders somebody was
saying that they have a problem with
cheerleaders
should we let our girls beast
cheerleaders is it time to rethink the
rules for NFL cheerleaders okay let's
see what they want let's see what the
[ __ ] problem is what is the problem
now
okay forty years ago this month a
visitor at the Dallas Cowboys
cheerleading tryouts described a scene
that was quote as tense as an open
casting call for a Broadway conduct
production with a hundred fifty women
the most envied celebrated and
sought-after in the country shivering in
an overly air-conditioned room ah that's
like being backstage at Letterman it was
[ __ ] freezing
the women spoke of starvation diets that
had lasted for weeks this sounds like
when you got a movie premiere coming up
the visitor a New York Times reporter
noted that the cheerleaders were paid
next to nothing $15 a game they had
stringent practice schedules as much as
five hours and night five nights a week
the only thing I agree with is how
little they pay they should pay more and
they could not appear where alcohol was
served at 10:00 parties of any sort or
where jury with the uniforms a Cowboy
Cheerleader above all else is beautiful
the article said at a time when the
squad was perhaps the most iconic such
case so what is the [ __ ] problem four
decades later the world may have changed
but the rules of professional
cheerleading appear to be essentially
the same no these people they don't know
what the [ __ ] they're talking about
first of all cheerleaders they used to
lead Cheers
before there was Diamond Vic the big
[ __ ] whatever they called the big
[ __ ] flat screens
and all the music go go shorty but all
that [ __ ] you know everybody clap your
hands before all of that [ __ ] they would
lead people in chairs but they wanted it
to became obsolete so now what they
really are is it just sort of dance
teams and then when there's a stoppage
of play they come out oh oh
buh-buh-buh-buh break it down right now
you just do something they just do some
[ __ ] this is just once again I swear to
god this is just this is just [ __ ]
I'm telling you like the women who are
going to complain about this no one's
going to ask you to be a cheerleader
this is like me being concerned with the
models at Coppertone being like are they
you know tanning is not the most healthy
you thing and in the end it's really I'm
just jealous because I don't have any
pigment and look according to the
internet like a [ __ ] is it time to
rethink this I don't think I've ever
seen with all of the true huge [ __ ]
gigantic [ __ ] problems out there I
don't think I've ever seen a time where
just like the most frivolous [ __ ] gets
kids bumped all the way up to the top
it's like all those [ __ ] [ __ ]
that somehow board the plane before
Group one what you're just looking how
to [ __ ] did that person get on two
people today got on not veterans no kids
not limping somehow got on before
everybody else it's just like what the
[ __ ] did they do and my buddy just sent
me something this is gonna be the new
scam in aviation is everybody just
paying money and extra [ __ ] just to be
able to get on that [ __ ] plane first
my buddy Dean Del Ray sent me this thing
it's like five grand a year five [ __ ]
grand a year you go to that you go to
your own private terminal at LAX and
then then they take you right to the
plane and you get on first so you know
what I decided I was like you know what
I'm just gonna pack less I'm gonna be
old Billy backpack and my backpack will
fit right underneath my [ __ ] chair
and then you guys in anybody else wants
to [ __ ] you know sit there like like
a like a bunch of [ __ ] hyenas trying
to get the spoils of a Lions kill I and
I'm not [ __ ] doing it all right I'm
gonna [ __ ] hang back and be like all
right all you [ __ ] it I quit okay I did
it the right way I started in the back
of the plane I worked my way up I was
promised a gold watch and the gold watch
was that I was gonna get on first it
just doesn't [ __ ] exist anymore
anyways what is uh what the [ __ ] was I
talking about
oh yeah so there's all these like so you
know it's funny and I just I just did
what these feminists are doing right
rather than dealing with overpopulation
climate change [ __ ] deregulated banks
we're gonna tackle cheerleading why
because it affects me and I love that I
went on that [ __ ] rant about people
getting on the plane first cuz I just
showed him just as [ __ ] bad as they
are
you know so god bless them let a [ __ ]
about a [ __ ] job they're never gonna
be offered how [ __ ] fully yourself are
you should I let my daughter cheer lead
well is she good-looking enough should I
let my son be the head of the math team
well did your son get your [ __ ] I'm
actually making fun of myself here
you're [ __ ] in him should I let my
kid read out loud
on the radio no bill for the love of God
no anyways policy genius everybody that
was just a little break that's what
feminists are concerned about now
cheerleading hey there's a swirl a trash
two times the size of Texas two miles
deep out in the Pacific Ocean I don't
give a [ __ ]
pull up pom-poms I don't give a [ __ ]
let's talk about cheerleading all right
policy genius life insurance isn't the
most enjoyable thing to think about most
people don't like thinking about dying I
can tell you right now I got a life
insurance policy and now all of a sudden
I you know I know it's like a weight off
my chest it's like I can [ __ ] leave
now and and nobody's gonna have a
problem and I'm not talking about dying
I'm talking about going out getting a
pack of smokes you never could be bad
but actually having life insurance is a
really good feeling as I just said I
literally feel like I could abandoned my
family like that's how relieved I am
that I have life insurance it's nice to
know that if anything were to happen to
you
immediately pictured a piano did anybody
ever bring a piano will up with a
[ __ ] rope did that really happen
and why would somebody walk under David
um anything happened to you your family
won't have to start a GoFundMe to stay
afloat well here's my question what
happens if something happens to my
family what about the guy here huh when
do I get to [ __ ] put my feet up
motivate your audience talk about your
experience with the product slash
service choose one to to copy points to
rotate into your spot
well I already told you how much I liked
life insurance I just did it before you
guys advertised here so I didn't use
policy genius but you know had their but
had I known that there was a policy
genius out there I would have used it
and would have saved myself a [ __ ]
small fortune right my loved ones would
be in cavea rather than tuna fish policy
genius is the easiest way to get life
insurance online in just two minutes you
can compare quotes from the top insurers
to find the best policy for you and when
you compare quotes you save money it's
that simple policy genius has helped
over 4 million people shop for insurance
and placed over twenty billion dollars
in coverage and they don't just make
life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
auto insurance and home insurance if you
care about it they cover it call to
action so if you've been avoiding
getting life insurance because it's
difficult or confusing I don't get it
mirror give policy genius a try just go
to policy genius comm for all you
dummies out there that's pol I see why
GE and I us genius is such a hard word
to spell isn't it get your quotes and
apply in minutes you can do the whole
thing on your phone right now
policy genius the easy way that could
bear and by labor Jerry's that whole
time I was just thinking about this
[ __ ] cheerleader thing you know I had
to starve myself and everything you mean
make sacrifices well get a [ __ ]
nutritionists you don't have to starve
you
have to eat foods that feel your body
yeah if you consider Starling I like how
like you know have you ever seen real
starving people with their distended
bellies you can count their [ __ ]
ribcage Lionel Hampton could come over
and play a [ __ ] song on that goddamn
tour so that's starving all right these
poor women starve themselves the air
conditioning is turned on too low just
imagine living in some [ __ ] war-torn
country and listening to that [ __ ]
argument I think one of the biggest
problems facing women today is the
question of cheerleading
all right helix everybody HELOCs you
ever wake up in the morning we'll do you
with regrets of what you've done
Jesus Christ telltale heart is your
roommate buried underneath your
floorboards and your best friend dad the
cop is coming over replaying the
terrible decisions you've made the
previous night over and over and over
Jesus Christ yes the kicking sweating
yelling or whatever she did to piss off
everyone in the bedroom will guess what
bud deciding to sleep on a shitty
mattress is your choice wait a second
are you telling me if I have a nice
mattress I won't regret decisions I made
as a younger man this might be the
greatest sales pitch I've ever heard in
my life what else can it do are you sick
of your dick staring down at your ball
bag when you wake up in the morning
wouldn't it be great if it was [ __ ]
pointing at the ceiling is it to say
there's a [ __ ] raccoon up there be
careful um anyways what the hell am I
here
deciding to sleep on a shitty mattress
is your choice but Bill buying a
mattress is so hard where would I ever
begin well you're in luck buddy because
helix sleep the mecca the mattress I've
been yelling at you to buy for almost
two years will change your life go to
helix sleep calm slash burg take their
two minutes sleep quiz and
match you to the perfect mattress what
kind of a creep reads other people's
sleep quiz and you're naked when you
sleep I mean Jesus with it sometimes in
the bottoms it's like tinder for them
for finding a mattress all the fun with
none of the next morning regrets and
misery and right now you can get up to a
dollar 25 off your mattress order at
helix sleep calm / / they have $100 a
hundred night trial free shipping and
won't send you creepy next day text
that's helix sleep calm / / for up to
$125 off your mattress order o lastly
but certainly not lethal certainly not
least least amps calm stamps calm never
closes print postage for letters or
packages at your convenience 24/7 print
postage for an email class right from
your computer the exact amount of
postage every time never under pay or
over pay you know I would tell you guys
that majored in communications let me
try my my broadcasting poi so I don't
you oh here we go
stamps.com saves you time and money
which you can use to grow your business
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the u.s. post office right
to your fingertips
check by and print you official US
postage for any letter any package any
class of mail using your own computer or
printer staff come makes it so easy even
your stupid kid can do it they'll send
you a digital scale automatically
calculates the exact postage stamps comm
will even help you decide the best class
of mail based on your needs you can even
take your daughter and put her on the
scale and weigh her just to see if she's
light enough to be a cheerleader no
needs at least an expensive postage made
up and there are no long-term
commitments and right now you too can
enjoy the stamps.com service with a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital scale
scale sorry go to stamps.com click on
the microphone stop the home page type
in bur that stamps comm enter birth
there we go now let's get on to the
questions for this week question number
one am I too fat to be a cheerleader
if I continue to take it in the face
will that extra protein make me
beautiful enough these are the
hard-hitting questions in cheerleading
all right Paul birdie special hey Bill I
just watched the Paul versus FERS E
special and just wanted to thank you for
promoting it look at that it was
hilarious and I can't wait for the next
all things comedy special on Comedy
Central
keep up the great podcast you maniac oh
yeah Paul virzi special did very very
very well so I want to thank everybody
for watching that virzi is vir Zi I'm
sure they got it streaming on their
website you know how those guys are
everybody knows what they're doing over
at Comedy Central and Paul's just the
first we're gonna we got three more
specials coming and we're picking all
comics that other comics like and I'm
very proud of the group that we have
coming I'm not allowed to say who they
are when I can I will all right that's
it all right advice for olive oil olive
oil number one
Benito Billy I'm another 22 year old
lady and long-term lover of the podcast
and truly all of your work to be honest
as an amazonian myself just shy of 6
feet well this is for that woman who
wrote in olive oil I wanted to reach out
and offer some advice to my girl olive
oil from last week i co-signed
everything you said about loving
yourself and some guy will love you just
the way you are but I just wanted to put
my two cents of advice in as well
Jill Jesus get on with it Dan which is
lift some weights girl thankfully my
prayers were answered around the time I
reached adulthood in the form of a nice
little waist-to-hip ratio and some chest
praise God but I was never satisfied
with my rear end until it I met my
husband who is jacked and he introduced
me to pumping iron and iron warts and
Egger bless his heart taught me how to
sculpt an ass out of muscle
I suggest she watches that movie starts
with the basic no supplements
except creatine weight gainer and coffee
don't waste money on any of the [ __ ]
GNC concoctions and finds some heavy
stuff to lift in the following ways
squat bench deadlift now she will get so
much self-confidence out of becoming
stronger than she has ever been I would
just say get a personal trainer too so
you're doing all this right you don't
[ __ ] up your back and with the
endorphins from exercise plus the
changes in her body
adding mass I really think she will love
it number two the tall skinny girl Jesus
Christ the [ __ ] assistant to here good I
don't want to update now clicking no
sorry
number two the tall skinny girl who
wrote in should move to New York and be
worshipped I feel for her
though because people used to tell me
stuff like that to my face all the time
they were just telling he i calling you
stretch you know well and then only the
type of type of [ __ ] you know eight-foot
[ __ ] whatever they say two tall women I
don't know I don't remember it's been a
long time since I've been in school 100%
of those people who said that to me 10
years ago are now pretty chubby at 30
while I look like the same slash better
than I did at 20 my boyfriend says I'm a
10 and he's a catch and a half I just
looked up Gigi had his numbers 510 and a
half tall 130 pounds almost the exact
same as this girl's she should also look
into squats leg lifts and protein thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself so I think what she
did was she embraced her body and made
it the best she could she could be I
think that's all great advice olive oil
hope you listening all right but only
thing I would add to that just make sure
you get a personal trainer get a
nutritionist and all that stuff and they
have the answers rather than [ __ ]
looking at the dope next to you being
like what are those dos breakers really
your eyes you're looking okay I'll just
do that
Alexa at my hospital oh Jesus dear bill
I work in a medical center that is very
up to date with technology in Beverly
Hills that I will not name my work
involves me visiting patients at their
sighs I walked into one of my patients
for him to find Alexa mounted on the
wall with an example question typed up
on a piece of paper
Alexa called my nurse my reaction was
she has a big [ __ ] emoji looks like a
smiley face are you freaking out is that
a freaking out smiley face I don't know
and I asked the RN that's registered
nurse
we have Alexa now as soon as I said
Alexa it lit up with that creepy blue
ring waiting for me to give it a command
I have no idea why patients need that in
the room because patients have remotes
that call the nurse's station yeah
because it's spying on you that also
controls the TVs I immediately thought
of you and chuckled love your work and I
agree a lot with you lady MD see that
the smart ladies go with old freckles
and you should go with those freckles a
celebrity podcast podcaster this Tuesday
in the voting booth
I say you vote for me me me me yeah yeah
yes I saw the McRib advertised recently
must be voting season again hilarious
yeah that's all creepy you know I flew
in and out of Boston from Newark Airport
and they had this magazine this was
tribute to Burt Reynolds so like I you
know I you know was great his movies his
stunts the women he loved I was like I
got to read this [ __ ] Burt Reynolds
they're not gonna make another guy like
this and I go I pick up the magazine I'm
looking around there's nobody there so I
walk over the restaurant I go where do I
pay for this and the lady just goes oh
at the self-checkout right over there
sweetheart and she points over to where
there had to been five million [ __ ]
things so I just said oh okay it's right
over there oh okay well thank you
sweetheart and I just walked over to the
rack and I [ __ ] put it back in I'm
not doing it enough [ __ ] doing that's
another thing too I [ __ ] refuse to be
my own cashier drawing the line is
saying I will I will [ __ ] eat a
goddamn Thanksgiving meal before I go to
the [ __ ] Airport
I'll bring my Reader's Digest I'm gonna
be that old guy I don't like new things
and you know what no one's gonna care
bill nobody's gonna care so just learn
how to check yourself out in the mirror
no silly at a store all right my wife
cheated on me by downloading tinder and
sending nudes hey Billy balls but
listening to your podcast for a few
years now and your advice see this is
somebody who never would have cheated in
the past they just were around a
computer too long Antonius like just
having heroin sitting on your table
eventually you can do something dumb
anyways but lets you podcast for a few
years now and your advice always makes
me laugh in hard times
here's something just happened me this
past week as hoping you could help me
out with I got married memorial take
irony of this year my wife has been
acting really distance lately and on
Sunday I asked her if she was seeing
anyone she told me no I've known this
girl for four years now and I knew she
was lying well I'll do great instincts
if you guys just got married in May this
is five months later it's gone this has
gotten this bad when I asked to look at
her phone she quickly deleted something
and refused to let me see your phone
physically attacking and scratching to
keep me from seeing it she then admitted
to downloading tinder about two weeks
ago and has been take talking to a guy
and sent him some pictures claiming to
never have met him and I believed her
I've been struggling these last few days
with a lot of emotions it's only five
months into the marriage is it best to
look at getting a divorce it would take
a lot of time to forget about what you
did especially since I will never really
know what transpired saw you an AC and
loved it thanks - go [ __ ] yourself yeah
dude you're five months in look if you
were like ten years in you're going
through a rocky period and I don't know
you have a couple of kids it's something
you work out maybe but yet this just
seems like if this is happening this
early on I don't think she wanted to
marry that's what I would have or
doesn't want to be married or I don't
know what or is sabotaging the whole
thing and at that point it's like well
hey
kudos to you because you did it yeah I
would get the [ __ ] out of that yeah I
mean as a kid did you drink this up was
that your dream woman five months in
senator or a [ __ ] hoo-ha what is
something I don't think it is yeah I
would I would get the [ __ ] out of that
you know that's a man she chooses like
physically attacked you too so I mean I
don't know that's good that's there's a
lotta that sounds like the beginning of
one of those they appeared to be a
happily married couple occasionally he
would showed up with odd scratches and
bruises but he quickly explained it away
saying he was working on his car then
one day he didn't show up for
Thanksgiving
his wife had recently been digging a
well in the backyard all right
I hate fat people oh Jesus dear Billy
bitty balls Billy bitty balls Oh Billy
bitty balls what's the matter I'm a
twenty year old sophomore in college and
I have a dilemma like the subject says
fat people really just disgust me Oh the
subject hate fat people are there are
too many examples to name but one that
really gets me is this lady in my math
class who sits next to me and will ramp
randomly start smacking her lips and
making this he spelt it M ehem and noise
yes ma'am she's doing that maybe she's
thinking about food I don't know there
is also this guy in my Hall who shits
literally three times a day
they must be wrapping his pizza and kale
or something because I see him go to to
his room with pounds of food at a time
my dislike isn't anything malicious and
I just can't help it but I am just stuck
between a rock and a squishy place and
surrounded on all sides by the fatties I
know this does not seem like a big that
big of a deal but I have a bit of a
temper and I'm afraid I'm going to say
something to one of the fatties and get
title nine right out of my school do you
have any tips to become a bit more
tolerant
I love the podcast Congrats on your role
in frontrunner you should grow that
mustache and keep it and go [ __ ]
yourself
I did grow that mustache I grew that
mustache when I had when I played the
cop way back on Chappelle's Show let's
see here uh I would just make a joke out
of it
how well do you know the guy who's
always disappearing
I would give my Sulu Russell name now
you can't do that that's me I don't know
yeah I know
it's like yeah you're supposed to be
tolerant but they just continue to eat
and they make weird noises and they
smell and you're supposed to just sit
next to them and be like well I feel bad
for them they have a [ __ ] problem you
know it's hard to feel bad for someone
that you know is gluttonous I guess but
that's just the way I'm wired like you
know all of these [ __ ] addicts and
all these goddamn people like I don't
know once you live with the [ __ ]
addict you just you you just yeah you
just have you don't have a lot of
patience for them I don't really know
what you're asking me sir I understand
what you say I would just find somebody
else in shape and I would just together
just make fun of them without them being
able to hear it you know most of the
time they're chewing anyway so it drowns
out their hearing so I think you'll be
alright I would just make jokes like
that other than that what are you
supposed to do you know
I don't know sing songs when they go by
that'd be funny if you just snapped by
Jesus Christ again how bad are you
trying to [ __ ] get you can't do any
of that and the thing is is you're not
really helping him you shouldn't
fat-shamed people but like it's also
like you know what I mean like you know
there's a little bit of arsenic in an
apple but it's still good for you like
that yeah if you could have like the
same level of arsenic that's in an apple
if you could have that level of shame
shaming at fat people I think it would
help him out a little bit why don't you
tie one of them to your bumper and drag
them to the gym I don't know I don't I
don't have the answers here recipe for
vegetable lasagna
I have no [ __ ] idea why I'm getting
this speaking of which um I have not
been eating well I consider myself a fat
[ __ ] right now and I I fetch I'm a
self-contained unit I will I will fat
shame myself or you guys could do it too
you know I always enjoy that
all right recipe for vegetable lasagna
dear bill I was recently listening to an
old podcast where you and you were
talking about a Thanksgiving oh god yes
well you made a shitty vegetarian
lasagna with carrots in it it was
horrible oh my god one of the worst
Thanksgivings ever made me think of a
great broccoli lasagna recipe that my
roommate and I would cook and I would
cook he's a battalion from Sicily well
those guys don't consider themselves
Italian they consider themselves
Sicilian and the recipe is from his
Italian grandmother so you know it's
going to be some good [ __ ] this isn't
healthy at all it's rich and creamy and
absolutely [ __ ] delicious as a
lasagna should be also it's super-easy I
can't remember the exact measurements
for each thing but we're gonna try
anyways oh you protection the recipe
while he gave me was the [ __ ]
ingredients what is this a cooking show
7-under grams of broccoli florins
flour butter and milk for the bechamel
sauce look up a basic lasagna recipe for
Beckham B CH AME L an amount of lasagna
sheets a few cloves of garlic chopped
olive oil fresh mozzarella parmesan or a
yeah tbsp of pesto depending on how much
bechamel you make let's ease pretty
simple like all great Italian dishes all
right I'm not gonna read all of this
[ __ ] cut up the broccoli all right I
don't know if somebody can figure that
[ __ ] [ __ ] out anyways if I've done an
hour I think I have all right that's the
podcast I don't always play Monday Night
Football tonight but I got to do some
sports tonight tomorrow to make sure I'm
ready for Tuesday and into this weekend
and I'm actually gonna do something that
all old men like to do I'm gonna take a
[ __ ] nap
I can't wait and you guys you have no
idea how difficult it is to be me
you know dealing with hard-hitting
problems like cheerleading
should we let women cheer lead I love
other cheerleading five feet away from
guys who are literally doing irreparable
brain damage to themselves most of whom
you know when they get to a certain
point either go crazy or kill themselves
but but let's let's not focus on that
anyways that's the podcast everybody
I'll check in on you on Thursday and I
don't know what I guess now I'm down to
watch and I'm gonna start watching the
Celtics and the Bruins now when I get
[ __ ] home to my my what Center rice
package and whatever they call the
basketball one the NBA hardcourt package
I don't know what the [ __ ] is his
package - is that micro aggressive my
center ice vagina is that what you
supposed to say I have no idea
all right go [ __ ] yourselves please
everybody just just for me in my
celebrity podcasting ego could you just
get out there and vote
because tomorrow is really really
important all right go [ __ ] yourselves
we'll talk to you Thursday